so much evil in your eyes wait did I
just steal your question there
I'm Jenny boy I'm Kelly Bryant we're
from legacies and we are going to
interview each other
Jenny boy we had this conversation
earlier today what was your first
impression of me when we met when I was
doing my screen test at Warner Brothers
and I thought she was my competition and
I was really confused when she started
talking to me and and saying how similar
that we looked and I was just really
thrilled I was like this girl is like
trying to throw me off it's some really
weird mental like mind games yeah that
does happen it does happen rooms and so
it's safest just like put your
headphones in was that like I saw her I
knew that there was twins I knew that we
were the only people there I was like
this is so crazy like we look alike cuz
she was a brunette at the time I was
like this is crazy this is so exciting
let's be friends and she was like oh
[Laughter]
that you were allergic to perfume that
day drew we talked about essential oils
beautiful okay yeah I had the same
question and you kind of already went
there yeah there's anything else you
want to say about the day that we met
when I met Jenny void I saw that she was
tall like me which made me happy and
she's really pretty and I was like oh
she must be a model which she was so
yeah okay Haley yeah
what's the most embarrassing or funny
thing you've ever seen me do on set
[Music]
you don't do a lot of embarrassing
things I think you think so oh my
favorite story are we talking about the
same one they do like singles on
everybody and moved into any boy dancing
and barbara Brown who was directing that
episode came up to Jenny and she didn't
know the choreography and so she was
like oh Jenny could you just like take
from that part thank you so much and
that like the choreography looks like
not bad but it was Jenny was so confused
and so I'm like only Jenny and you see
your girl like start doing the dance of
shoes it was like also there were like
hundreds of extras and crew just waiting
everybody we did an entire take just for
this one moment to get me looking at
Kayleigh doing this specific move I
think I've looked at the director I
looked at you did it with confidence
thank you be role somewhere oh okay
what's the most embarrassing or funny
thing you've seen moody one says a lot
of yeah like in between takes and stuff
she's always trying to make people laugh
she's guys some really awesome go to
dance moves
oh yeah fortnight is how you learned
some of them right oh I do the fortnight
move you do that for a night news yeah
like kpop moves a lot that was like
season one I was like really into like
teaching everybody like that kpop moves
yeah I've calmed down she's trying to
calm down you got off so easy there's
got to be something I'm gonna remember
something tonight and just be like let's
see if you act like an idiot all the
time it's not like shocking right
something's normal oh I can tell them
about flicking chicken Oh
blinded Jenny voice okay Lee weave that
was bad simply been gifted all of these
[ __ ] chickens so they're called
flicking chickens okay it might be go
ahead but these little like rubber
chickens that are super stretchy and you
like pull them back and shoot them at
things or people and they will stick to
the wall someone's face I usually have
very good aim at flicking chicken and I
am the frickin chicken champion yeah but
it was her birthday I almost didn't get
angry at her she was like sobbing and
one of the 80s goes do you want to call
the nurse and before Jenny could even
respond II would know yeah Katie likes
to create excitement
she's very unexpected we both had that
one right okay
Kaylie yeah what was it like to master
all those Japanese lines that Josie had
to say in episode 204 oh it was nerve
wrecking just because I don't know I
needed to make my grandpa proud I had so
GOI there who is actually obviously
fluent in Japanese so every time I'd
finish to take out just look at him and
be like that's right because I got thing
like I kept saying like she they do
which like it's been completely
different than like she dated and I just
like kept saying it wrong and I knew it
too but like nobody in the crew
obviously could be like oh clearly she
said that incorrectly so it was like
just me and the translator and so G and
so every time I just look at him and be
like it's like to know versus to do it
completely changes the meaning dang yes
you are number three
Jenny Boyd yes what was it like to film
the scene in episode 203 when Lizzie was
making out with Sebastian but it looked
like she was just kissing the air I was
there for this oh yes you were there
everybody came out and watched first of
all even though they weren't filming
it's just like no audience if
village thanks girl yeah it was um it
was probably the weirdest thing I've
ever done in my career um everyone like
burst into hysterical laughter you
killed it though you really did great
thank you
it looks good yeah I mean I don't know
how else you do that yeah yeah it felt
like forever like it was just a year
every single time I had to do it and I
had to do it like a lot eight ten times
yeah yeah you get handed the hardest
things like having to switch back
between like being possessed and normal
having to kiss the air but like any
point is impressive it's true thank you
okay Kaylee yeah be honest
oh god do you think Jesse and Landon
make a good couple
why or why not here's the thing if you
take Landon and Josie and take out all
of the external factors meaning like you
know Landon actually being in love with
hope right thing they are a very like
illogical couple like I think they're
very sweet we get I just spit I didn't
see it okay I don't know I think that
there's something really sweet about
being like best friends with somebody
and that turning into something else I
love that that's really cute I do too
but ya know you go you go you're it's
your question no just okay I just love
like their awkwardness because I think
it is actually a really good reflection
of what a lot of real-life relationships
are like at the beginning you know
there's just me a colles during each
other out kind of thing or just
awkwardness is you know human yeah I
think it's really cute so yeah I think
it's sweet
but I can see why a lot of people would
be upset with it just because like
Landon and hope we're always like in
love that was like the epic love and
then Josie's like I think people need to
come around to the fact that it's
actually really cute yeah Jake wait l
don't have a problem
Salo and Jenny Boyd Jenni Boyd yes be
honest do you think Lizzie and Sebastian
make a good couple
why or why not
oh well it depends on what our
definition of good is all right
what is your take are they healthy as a
couple is he not really an any couple on
our so healthy yeah who Landon and Josie
there had they have really good
communication they do have really good
communication that's true okay um but is
there a certain ste meanness their
esteem II yes you guys are both
beautiful thank you
yeah I I think it's the right thing for
Lizzie in this moment because
everybody's got to learn those lessons
you know what I'm saying yeah you know
everybody likes the bad boy this is true
you start out and you were like a Damon
and Elena ship for you so this is like
very appropriate yes maybe they gave me
what I wished for
yeah it's all about persistence great ok
here we go mmm Kaylee yeah that's my
on-screen sister me who do you think
would be a good romantic match for
Lizzie mg she loves Lizzie open your
eyes mg is so cute right there but he
loves her so much like he's willing to
do so much and I think that like if
Lizzie just like sat down and like like
I feel like Lizzie is the type of gal
that like enjoy is like being taken out
on like a nice day like she wants to be
taken out yes an mg would be the type of
boyfriend that would enjoy like taking
like taking her out like taking care of
her yeah and like making her coffee
every morning yeah like fest in bed I
think they'd be so cute together
there's always time there is time yeah
okay Jennifer Boyd
as my own screen sister mm-hmm who do
you think would be a good romantic match
for Josette Saltzman
so Kaley is off the team that Josie's
left alone yeah for a little while okay
and then and then when she's ready again
um no one in the current cast really
jumps out to me I think you had a new
fresh
Oh interest oh yeah okay yeah
would they be like a supernatural or of
human descent and if so supernatural
what branch of supernatural I think if
we went with a human Josie would you
spend her whole time just trying to like
save and defend them big facts so I
think she needs somebody who can like
look out for themselves like hold their
own yeah um so yeah supernatural
interesting and whatever heart desires
it's a natural maybe a witch oh yeah
okay or an unknown supernatural learn
about yet like that yeah ah oh wait I
just asked you never right
Oh denied it no you didn't yeah I said
no what no yeah it's my turn to ask you
right wait did I just steal your
question okay
Keeley yeah if the merge does happen
yeah
who do you think would win Lizzie
Saltzman I really do those different
opinions I really do think that Lizzie
Saltzman should win she no I think she
will win I think as much as she's like
going on her like journey to be like
Josie Saltzman yeah push comes to shove
she's going to let you win what if
Lizzie selfless the end I don't think
that she would do it on purpose
I really think that Josie would go in
like pretending like hey like we're
gonna do this it's gonna be fine and
then she'd be like I think that Josie is
more powerful than Lizzie you really do
think so yeah definitely
I find what you had to say about
Lizzie's knowledge and studying of
witchcraft really interesting that
you're talking about onset oh yeah I
don't think we should tell people that
that's a big plot point that might not
even happen it might but I think it's
interesting of like musi Saltzman just
isn't as comfortable doing spell work as
Josie is because she doesn't like allow
herself to write I think yeah I think
Josie Josie is more studious Josie has a
natural affinity for it and I think I
don't think she's more powerful I think
Lizzie is equally as powerful it's just
like how they go about being so powered
but also you can direct your power very
well and I'm probably more like all over
the place but has the thing is like I
feel like Josie might be like trying to
like zoom zoom Oh spell and you'd be
like okay she just got we could we can
argue about this forever oh we've
already had this if the merge does
happen who do you think would win okay
if you could have any character from The
Vampire Diaries universe make an
appearance on legacies who would you
choose and why I would choose to mmm
Caroline Forbes because I really want to
see our dynamic as a family and Damon
Salvatore because fun exciting
unpredictable just like this would love
to see her interact Lizzie interact yeah
I pay to watch that yeah okay same
question if you have any character from
The Vampire Diaries universe well I got
my one win of the century which was
fighting hard enough to bring Kai Park
so since day one she has been fighting
persistence is key if you annoy the
writers of legacies enough you will get
what you want is what I have learned so
Kai Parker was my big one and then like
one of my favorite characters from The
Vampire Diaries was also Katherine
Pierce
so like I like the evil characters so to
have because I mean there's something
exciting about a human bad as opposed to
like a monster bad because a battle of
wits is very interesting to me yes so
yeah agreed
yeah are we done that was our ET
interview you can watch legacies 9:00
8:00 central on Thursdays Oh me on the
CW
[Music]